Chris Webber Turner Sports NBA analyst
he'll be hosting TNT's players only
coverage tomorrow night at 8:00 Eastern
it's the rockets and the Thunder
followed by the pelicans and the
Clippers also part of this year's NC
double-a tournament that begins and ends
on TBS c-webb good to have you this
morning how are you doing great dad
thanks for having me we were talking
movies how many movies have you been in
uh well maybe maybe one maybe one I know
I know in the beginning my career I was
asked a lot not turned him down thinking
that you know I'd have time so I wish I
could go back but I think I've been in
one maybe would you turn down I think
blue chips is the one that probably
affected my career the most is right
after you know right after I call the
timeout so always like was pork out this
summer I would do everything you know if
I didn't maybe I would have jumped in
the movie but it's funny because I
played a you against penny so many years
so I knew how great 10 he was and when
Shaq didn't sack didn't know so every
day after they exhumed blue chips they
work out like at a gym and Shaq called
me like a few weeks before they started
feeling blue tipz like get ready we're
gonna get you and then after blue chips
you know the rest of it penny went there
so for blue chips was one I could
definitely remember well you think that
if they didn't have if blue chips didn't
come out that in a check didn't play
with penny then Shaq would have told her
Lando to draft you instead of penny oh I
know it's a fact
I spoke to Shaq about it before the
draft after the draft and probably like
three months ago about it so we always
talked about it but yeah we laughed but
no that's that's serious I you know you
got to play everyday with a guy for two
months so you know a guy you know
intimately what he likes to eat hang out
you become good friends so I definitely
you know if I was shocked I was did the
same thing first of all the Poincare
like like him at the time but secondly
the fact they got to play together he
was throwing sack oops in the summer of
course you're gonna draft that back
would you rather have six rings or five
rings and an Oscar mmm
six rings so you take Michaels resume
over Kobey's I mean Kobe's I'd take
Kobe's I mean congratulation to Kobe by
the way so when it's our animators sure
that's really cool yeah I mean but you
know you asked me so I'd rather I'd
rather you know have Michael Jordan 92
dream team you know change the game my
own shoe
you know and every player after him has
to pay homage including Kobe so whether
it's Kobe LeBron it had to be a mic
first so I'd still take Mike's best shoe
ever made was 100 I can't say one now
you got me going through a list adidas
formed the adidas top ten the Barclays
with the strap the black when I forgot
the name of it but I was a 92 mine
the see where I learned quake that came
out my second yeah yeah but but
seriously my no I'm not just saying I'd
like five because only one could make
that list and let me see let me see let
me see let me see
Oh back in the day the Patrick killings
were nice the odorous was nice so like
like six or seven she was growing up on
definitely she could hear back at the
thing and of course there is no Jordan
yeah how many Jordans do you have like
did your wife make you clear out here
you should know I didn't I didn't have
crazy sneakers like that like I'm a god
I like to wear a lot of difference
because so I was I'm a big Jordan guy
but I never was a gotta you know like I
don't know the numbers of the Jordans
and which ones come on things like that
but rip Hamilton has a pair of Michael
Jordan golf shoes oh my god they're so
sick like I haven't even seen them on
the market so that's what she what I
would love to give right along like I
think a retro pair of Jordans golf shoes
but no I never was a big a big collector
now he's see Webb Turner Sports NBA
analyst has breaking ankles
replaced dunking on somebody oh that's a
great quick breaking anchor my hitting
at the Reed
I think it's just the stickers talking
on somebody yeah if you break the ankle
in and hit the three
yeah it's nasty someone did something to
Paul George the other day he didn't even
fall he just went two steps forward and
it was just it was sick so yeah now you
can definitely get embarrassed to hold
out the way you gotta be careful on the
chronic suppose up in the air get don't
go on do you have your moment where you
dunked on somebody and you're a moment
when somebody dunked on you thank you
remember no I mean this is this is very
stereotypical and it but it's true I
don't remember kids don't go now I'm
sure I'm sure some people are gonna
remind me so let me put that out there
but yeah I mean to me it was always if I
could get my tumbler Sean Bradley or
Patrick you I mean no Rome Alonzo
Mourning back then you know was his
honor like a badge of honor to dunk on a
shot blocker yeah but everybody dunked
on Sean Bradley Chris no not the way I
did not I should have got technicals I
should have been kicked out of games the
way I talked on it was really no no no
not like I'd crying in forgive one I'm
talking about body to body on top of
them and you know no he was he was a guy
I really like Duncan I know a lot of
people got him but nobody nobody body to
body found Bradley aside for a couple
people but yeah the best shot blockers
you always wanted don't go on and on you
know I got a few of them
Philadelphia's put up billboards trying
to entice LeBron to go to Philadelphia
I remember Sacramento didn't did the
Maloof brothers put up a billboard to
keep you in Sacramento yeah they did
what did they say on that billboard they
said something like please stay we will
mow your lawn and and what happened I
told Mario that they doing the game but
you know we have to be judicious in
where we talk about sometimes that
sometimes not all the time but and I was
telling him I was going to say I'm gonna
tell the behind don't believe what they
put on those billboards because I still
haven't gotten my grass
and those guys carbon trade Mirko you
know a couple years later after they beg
you to stay Wow don't fall for the
Billboard man that's like don't fall for
that that's the oldest that's the oldest
trick in the book and it only works for
the owners how did it feel to get traded
Oh like somebody loses right in their
forehead like some I just spit in your
forehead and kicks you out the door and
then you want to get back at them and
think think how do you how do you I
guess compartmentalize or package that
anger that you have or do you want to be
in a personal that's that's the whole
part of being a professional you know no
one really sees what goes on behind the
scenes and the recruitment and think
about it all of the oprah aha moments
that you have looking in each other's
eyes
you know dreaming of a championship and
going away with good feelings and moving
your family and you know cuz for me it
was you know a trade with the Lakers on
the table and they weren't letting me go
so they really had to convince me to
stay now at the end of my career let me
say I'm very happy it was a blessing to
go to Sacramento but at the time you
know there were other teams and other
players that I'm kind of forced to hand
and going to play with and so I had to
believe I really have to believe and I
did
and so after believing and buying into
it you know when you're like oh so you
guys don't get it you know it's kind of
its kind of a you know it's kind of a
kind of a slap in the face but you got
to learn to move on and deal with the
foot at the time I mean I think the only
way you deal with it is family friends
and just trying to be a professional
junior Smith sat down for a game for
throwing soup at an assistant coach ever
have one of those moments throw the bowl
I guess I don't know I you know they
cost you the game are we aligned the
buffets
so things I don't know song I know I've
never had any anything or anything like
that and yeah I we didn't know at the
time it was soup when we did the game
but when I heard you know you have to
laugh at that but those guys need
something so hopefully the soup roll and
hopefully something else going hanging
out hopefully some concern around for
them as they're trying to trying to pull
some strings and wins together but now
I've never heard anything like that yeah
I'm concerned though with what I see
with Cleveland because even with this
influx of young talent I you know I
watched them and you know the nets are
running them ragged you know teams are
going in there and playing and beating
them so I I mean it's not it it's not a
foregone conclusion they go to the
finals I don't know if Boston's ready it
feels like Toronto is still just gonna
be Toronto and that's good dangerous but
not ready to take that next step
handicap the East how do you think this
plays out I think well I agree with you
on the fact I just don't know if
Cleveland has enough and that's
something whenever you have the crime
you seem to always have enough and Kevin
Love not playing so that's gonna bring
back a lot but if you look at I really
don't have a shot blocker yeah Justin
Thompson is he's a beast in the paint
but this is really not a piece he's just
really did it like he was you know maybe
on a thin Marlys and other type of level
when he used to rebound and get in there
you know I like Austin and I like you
know all the guys they brought over and
he needs a number two to stuff up and
maybe that's just waiting on Kevin Love
when he gets back but I just really I
just really don't see it I like all the
dishes they have I like Clarkson here
but it just doesn't seem like they have
that second guy I do believe in Toronto
this year they have the deepest bent in
the league I think their bench leads the
league in scoring a system so I do
believe in Toronto's bench I don't
necessarily believe in the play calling
offensively and what will happen in the
playoffs but I do think they're capable
of I agree with you on Boston I just
don't know if they're ready yet without
hey work there so um but but Cleveland I
just right now it's really hard to see
and they don't
only had like six practices as of last
week so I don't see how they're gonna
get better in a hurry if you can have
any player you want to build your team
around right now and you get them for
the next five years at the age they're
at right now so you get LeBron but
you're getting for the next five years
you can have any player that you're
starting your - I'm going to give you
the first rap thing oh that's a good one
okay I'm gonna try to be quick about
this the first five years I like this
either I mean this is a hardened
Westbrook Anthony Davis cousins five
years five years five is curry Durant
I'm gonna go with oh oh it's gonna be
Durant or Harden and I'm gonna oh I'm on
oh come on I'm gonna take harder just
because I'm gonna take Harlem because
because he can make players better so I
can get a cappella I can get other guys
I can get a big fella if I take Durant
as my first I might have to draft I
still get a point guard to help
everybody so I'm gonna go with harden
just off the top to hit yeah I'm gonna
take ad not a not a bad choice I if you
called me and I had hard I might even
trade you for that I just think Davis if
Davis ever played with the point guard
oh my god you imagine that I mean this
guy's dominating and he doesn't even
he's never had a point guard you know
what I'd rather in half instead of a
point guard
I'd rather have a Kyle Korver on the
corner and I'd rather him have Anderson
in the corner I read in that foo
shooters because I love him and cousins
together first of all by himself
first people I agree but him and cousins
together I'm telling you I is gonna work
in my opinion if they know how to defer
to each other you know that Kentucky
guys and I watch them closely this year
wanting to hopefully not hoping that it
would work and trying to watch the
dynamics of it but I was too together
when they can see the pick-and-roll they
can switch that one can be the
three-point line the other inside they
can pass the high-low to each other so I
mean I really hope for everybody's sake
for the NBA say they
keep those two cats together and get
some shooters but they need a lot of
help and it's been unfair yeah ad like
they've been you know a lot of people
you know a friend of mine was telling me
other day how many guys pass players
never made it out the first round and
still it's celebrated and it's funny
this is after 10 or 15 year career and
so I think that this young kid that's
been around bad teams came to the move
teams that have had problems you know as
far as recruiting and things like that I
think he's one of the best players that
we've had and has always shown that so I
love his game I just hope that he gets
some help because he's gonna be a guy
we're gonna look back and say you know
why he was like a Dominique Wilkins he
just filled the star cheese you know
what and we never talked about the TM
sorry teams they had during those seven
years stretches that were terrible
wasting guys to rear so hopefully Lucas
will help so thank you Chris keep
stirring it up have fun players only
night and of course the NCAA tournament
thank you all right that's a c-webb
players only TNT that's tomorrow night 8
Eastern Rockets Thunder pelicans
Clippers also NCAA tournament begins and
ends on TBS CBS or CBS involved in that
as well
TBS TNT and truTV starting Tuesday March
13th the first four on truTV for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]